i mean obviously it's basketball so i'm
using the word hatred sports hatred but
was it like what was like the disdain
you guys had for the warriors during
those years
oh yeah we didn't [ __ ] with them
i didn't like them
uh
i'm a huge fan
of all of them now though it's crazy uh
even down to like even like down to
draymond like we had this thing it's
like you hate to play against draymond
but like
it's really hard not to like dude
speak with his chest
say what he feel passionate about the
game
he come on the court not to like you
like that's he's the kind of guy who you
hate but you would love if he was if he
was that if he on your team thought
we're going to be the best of friends
but it's like he want to go to war he
don't want to play
like he's one of the guys that's like
running through screens
basketball he's doing what i like like
he one of those guys he's a blind guy a
glue guy like
you need him around you know what i'm
saying you need his voice around his
whatever like
clay another guy keep his head down he
gonna shoot it
i loved playing against clay because
clay is one of the only people like i
don't got in my battles with kyle korver
jj reddick all of them push off get mad
i'm all over them roughing them up
talking [ __ ] to him you know what i'm
saying
klay thompson
does not complain the refs like he's not
going to do the oh ref look at him he ah
man you gravitate klay thompson you
holding him that man goes
chop your wrist down so fast and i was
like bro i love this young light skinned
brother man
this dude don't care man he willing to
fight me
like that's how i felt about clay i'm
like clay is willing to fight me bro
just to get off this screen he doesn't
care he looked dead at the ref and
pushed me off like
hands to my neck push
i'm gonna fall back like this they don't
call the offensive foul and clay just
ran down the court like he didn't give a
[ __ ] like and i was like dawg i love
these dudes i just hate them for now
like i hate them yeah it felt like um
cause you got to keep seeing them and it
just felt like a serious like
i mean one of the more i feel like the
probably the most serious basketball
beef beef that we've seen
since the 90s it was
it's two different styles yeah and we
kind of knew we all knew like
whoever wins the most of this this
little
war we got going on whoever wins the
most chips basketball is headed in that
style
that's what was scary about like we knew
it meant more because we like bro like
the kids are gonna either continue to go
to the post and want to shoot fadeaways
well they gonna think this [ __ ] okay
they're shooting this [ __ ] from half
course [ __ ] like we was talking no
we've been talking about this [ __ ] like
i remember being switched like man you
want to shoot that [ __ ] before he let
him shoot that [ __ ] for 40. [ __ ] him
like that's the conversation being so
i'm gonna come
hey switch man [ __ ] you want to shoot
that [ __ ] from 40 let him shoot that
[ __ ] from 40 dog shoot that all night
[ __ ] like that's what we that's how i'm
feeling when i'm really on the court
like go ahead let him bro i wish you
would pull it
pull that bro please before we run this
down y'all throw like please shoot that
yeah that's how we felt about it till
this little [ __ ] started making
it yeah but it's like once he started
making it now t lu looking at us at the
drawing board like hey y'all gonna get
out there so what we gonna do
you shocked yeah you shocked me making
it now like it got it got to that point
it's like bro
when i think about it now i'm just like
bro
i don't i i keep saying basketball
changed
like they ruined it type of thing but
i'm like you ruined the version that i
like
i just feel like it's just it's just the
version i like i mean you really when
you really think about it pound for
pound yeah how basketball it is today
it's scary how good they are